donut movie rips off the slow-motion
look how he can see things before they
happen vision from Sherlock Holmes man I
don't care how fast his brain processes
things there's not enough time for him
to keep turning his head and looking at
all the options like this it must be
there by 7:00 fuck doubt did they
actually hire Jamie Chung and then ask
her to cover up for American accent with
the most stereotypical Chinese accent
ever so this movie is saying that once
wily sped off from Columbia University
Bobby was able to run to his car pull
out into Manhattan traffic and somehow
catch Wiley who never stops Bobby is
clearly behind a silver car at a blue
car in this shot but now there's a black
car in front and the only driver in New
York history to give it about a honking
horn politely moves over for reasons
unknown Bobby and Wiley pass a mobile
gas station here then pass it again here
and here and just to be different one
more time here we've seen Wiley
anticipate people opening car doors and
be downright Sherlock Holmes Ian when it
comes to finding bike paths but a car
coming out of a parking garage ends up
being his kryptonite Wiley apparently
has a homing beacon on him because no
matter where he goes or what kind of
crazy rowdy takes people can find him
with no problem now dude all you have to
do is honk your horn and a bunch of
helpful New Yorkers will get out of your
way remember and then while he decides
that now is the time to file a complaint
against someone who is clearly a
psychopath giving said psychopath more
time to catch up to it
rebuy Jesus movie wastes a good 12
minutes telling us something that could
have taken 10 seconds this guy is a
degenerate gambler
got it this guy would never have an
apple on his desk at least not a ripe
one unless the script calls for him to
stab something with the pencil I got to
admit I didn't expect the bike messenger
movie to turn into a game of Metal Gear
Solid I'm gonna need to change the
delivery address on that envelope he
only just now thought to use the ticket
number to change the delivery address on
the package how did this asshole ever
make detective I still don't get what
happened did I do something to piss you
off or something no I told you it's it's
a private matter can't she just say that
her family is moving to America and to
the apartment and leave it at that it's
really no need for secrecy except for
the illegal money thing and Vanessa
doesn't need to know about that you can
walk around with all that money where
are you going now just treat where
Selam I can't tell you anything about
this money except where I'm taking it
just a piece of cop stops by later
asking where I went huh
oh yeah but I'll go yeah but we can't
can't this old you just make a simple
phone call to sister Jan and say hey I
got the money do your thing they know
each other it's not like Nima's making a
money exchange between strangers check
that to you ok couch a doesn't take cash
so what would sister Chen have exchanged
the ticket for a bank transfer there
seems to be no reason why this money
exchange needs to be so complicated
dangerous and over all fucked up up top
of this bus man you would have really
been that hard to tell Manny that it was
life or death then the cops were
involved and stopped looking around like
a movie douchebag or call the boss and
tell him what's going on
what so they're neck and neck most of
the race and then wily wrecks but then
he's able to get up and catch back up to
Manny what is this mario kart
conveniently timed truck in the middle
of the road during a chase scene cliche
this wreck sends Wylie flying
horizontally several feet if not several
yards but then he lands like someone who
just fell off the couch wait really does
this look anything but intentional to
you apparently an ambulance does not
need a trained medical professional
riding along with a patient and cracked
his ribs she's been riding this whole
way and the driver doesn't see her in
the rearview mirror and even a bad
driver looks at his mirrors from time to
time even if it's only by accident well
I made it all the way back to the
impound lot time to check my rearview
mirrors for traffic movie briefly turns
into a Red Bull video why is this
asshole climbing up there's no other
place for Wiley to go all I have to do
is stand down here and Wiley is either
caught by the guy behind him or
basically jumps right into your arms
thank you
this guy Angus is working on a car for
some reason while two fugitives are
riding around on bikes in the impact
also he gets up from the van in this
shot and then he gets up from the van
again in the next shot Ruby says exactly
what the audience is thinking how did
this asshole not hear or see why they
coming out of the impound even if he
just got here he would have least been
able to see or hear all the commotion in
the garage and not be standing here like
a dumbass so that Wiley can take his
bike
I need a flash mob like five minutes ago
and if I didn't have to make this
fucking sense video this is the point
where I'd stop watching the scene where
they round up all the bike messengers in
the city is just like that part in the
Amazing Spiderman with a full
all the crane operators only somehow
more stupid if NEMA could get to
Chinatown this fast why didn't she just
deliver this herself
in fact why didn't she just take a sick
day from her job and say fuck it the
only customers who apparently ever come
into this bar or bike messengers ain't
no the thing about these folks and have
a testify good point
now what's keeping you from shooting the
guy and getting the ticket suck it
douche bag so here's the so-called flash
mob is this really what they were all so
excited to get out and do I mean I
thought we were gonna see a rumble or
something that this is borderline
harmless and certainly not exciting okay
so way back here the time was 625 now
let's take a look at what happened since
then Wiley and Manny got into a
dick-measuring contest that started in
Central Park and ended at 28th Street
and while I admit those are some pretty
long dicks
it ends with Wylie getting smashed by a
car and knocked unconscious god knows
how long he was unconscious but then
they stick him in an ambulance and all
that illegals that Bobby torturing Miley
happens that probably should have been
the end of it but there's this long
sequence at the impound Bobby takes
Wiley to the impound in his Mazda 6
would you left behind at the crash site
we see a cast on Wiley so they would
have had to have gone to the hospital
immediately gotten medical attention
found Bobby's car and then go to the
impound and do the Red Bull video all in
five minutes I'm sorry this kid is cute
but he's stuck in China a nema lost 50
grand there's no way this delivery
happens who he rubs the impossible time
in the face of viewers like we're just
supposed to accept that might have to
put on the suit someday but not yet man
no suit job is going to hire a guy with
15 years of light messaging on his
resume I'm just saying you have already
reached the summit of your particular
chosen career path
well life's hard turns out the King Cole
chasing a bicycle tricky and then the
liquid scum
yeah yeah oh really
what Oh basic playset yeah yeah okay
okay just give me break
do you think for second flashmob like
five minutes ago
you're so one of my skulls didn't you
oh yes I know you did it belong to a
neighbor of yours
I will my damage you're really
aggressive I've never hooked up with oh
thank you before so she's got a dirty in
here don't you think that's the idea